I'll Karamoja Tia has been living in
Gaeta for more than four years now
refugees from Sudan built the market
here al khair tia sells basic food
supplies and utensils to refugees and
local residents the entrepreneur once
owned a thriving store in his hometown
of alchemy r in the nuba mountains in
Sudan but when the region came under
bombardment by the Sudanese army he fled
with his family to South Sudan I know it
took us almost seven days because the
children were young and they were not
used to walking long distances a lot
only a limo with a wall of admission in
2011 tens of thousands of civilians had
already begun fleeing before the bomb
attacks they were only able to take bare
essentials ending up stranded in the yi
de Forest 14 kilometers south of the
Sudanese border we get a Nana all of our
food and houses were burned down there
was nothing left these children are
suffering they've been on a row for days
and we have no food to give them that's
a mini loom de that was almost five
years ago now there are more than 70,000
refugees living here in their makeshift
community with its cafes and schools
they farm sell their produce on the
market or make things in the workshops
but the camp has never been officially
recognized by the United Nations High
Commissioner for Refugees it's too close
to the unsecured border with Sudan and
is said to be a hideout for Sudanese
rebels the issue is testing relations
between the neighboring countries with
the South Sudanese government demanding
the camp's closure the UNHCR has been
trying to convince refugees to relocate
to two of their new camps further east
they're also situated close to the
border but not in the area affected by
the conflict says the organization the
services they get in in a joint talk and
palmera better
they have secondary school education
primary school education access to
health services programs for income
generation it is a place also where the
safety of humanitarian workers is is
guaranteed but the edge wrong talk camp
is already nearing its capacity with
around 33 thousand refugees seven
thousand more and it would be full and
new refugees arrive every day filling
the camp's rapidly there's little hope
that it could house the 70,000 people
living in Geeta so far only a few
thousand have gone to a jawan thok many
are put off by the Sudanese army base
nearby they are the troops they fled
from and the refugees in Geeta don't
know whether they'd be able to work in a
jawan thok or would just rely on aid
supplies I thought I'd Donovan I will
not go because it will only lead to more
problems in poverty than haga honestly
that's the reason why I refused to go I
will stay in HIDA no theta like others
here alcaldia doesn't want to lose his
newly built life and he won't just as
long as the yida refugees aren't forced
to move on